puede que los civiles de nagorno karabaj
y azerbaiján tengan al fin un pequeño
respiro luego de que las autoridades
armenias y azeríes acordarán un cese al
fuego humanitario que inició a
medianoche del domingo
'francia que ayudó a mediar celebró la
tregua advirtiendo que el cese del fuego
debe ser respetado de manera estricta
por ambas partes estaremos muy atentos a
eso y seguiremos comprometidos con
asegurar que las hostilidades se sienta
en forma duradera y que negociaciones
creíbles puedan dar inicio rápidamente
la región separatista de nagorno karabaj
está habitada mayormente por armenios y
desde el 27 de septiembre ha sido el
escenario de fuertes choques en los que
cientos de personas han muerto el cese
del fuego llega luego de que un ataque
con misiles en la ciudad a serie de
ganja avivar a la violencia dejando
docenas de muertos y heridos incluidos
niños ahora ellos deben y serán
considerados responsables de este crimen
nos vengaremos en el campo de batalla
los separatistas armenios aseguran que
fue una respuesta a los ataques del
ejército de azerbaiyán en la ciudad más
grande de nagorno karabaj y en otros
lugares de esta disputada región mixto
cómo puede la comunidad internacional
ser tan indiferente con la gente de
estepona care
este es el segundo intento de tregua que
se produce luego de otro alto el fuego
por el que medio rusia y fue violado a
las pocas horas los enfrentamientos son
los peores que vive en la región desde
1994 cuando una tregua acabó con la
guerra entre ambas partes